welcome my name is Belle ok lo and i
work with the International Center for
Research on women on base in Arabic
Kenya and I would like to respond to
laundry my eagerness forum blog about
the youth yes I agree that the youth are
a very very important segment of our
society and for a long time that we left
out of a developmental initiatives and
what I like to see is that they you
should not really look forward and wait
for other people to do things for them I
would like to see a situation where in
the next year or so the youth are either
learning or their army and they've got
all the brains are like them to exercise
their minds more or like them to think
much deeper about what they can do
instead of what we can do for them of
course it will be a censure that the
government's provide them with an
enabling environment to not only think
but also to act thank you very much